top of the morning to you ladies germs
it's your boys big mood back for another
I don't intro this show every he's
always like hello everyone and welcome a
big mood look ya'll today we got the man
the myth the legend David saw himself
back
we're bring him back a couple of guests
but we want to bring on people that you
all may know or you would actually like
for some reason we like David so we
brought him on I miss who I was before I
met David a piece of [ __ ] improved your
life you know when I first met Gina she
just got her boob job they were like up
to my [ __ ] cheeks dude and she was
she was telling me how did the process
of like having to massage them and break
up the scar tissue and [ __ ] I learned so
much about boob augmentation from her
when we first met oh my god you guys
just opened up like one of my first
friends but when I came to LA that we
made for Danielle Lee oh that's right
one yeah it's so funny because she's
like one of those people that are
relatively thin right but she's so out
of shape because I remember he liked my
fat where she met me I was [ __ ] huge
so we went to talk about that we
wouldn't we went hiking yeah yeah I've
never seen a [ __ ] struggle so much
going up a hill dude like it was three
steps and there was like cool I'm making
friends we gotta go hang out I'm gonna
try to be friends and he takes me hiking
like I don't want this friend actually
met her through her stepbrother right so
he used to go to the same junior high I
did he's a year younger yep aids boy
well I gotta talk about this this dude
was notorious it's like four hour bus
stop well he was notorious rated to me
who's the tourist because he wouldn't
share his fruit topia drink with anybody
because he was afraid he was gonna get
AIDS
exactly I remember this conversation
because there was one of his friends
that was asking the
swig of his a fruit punch Fruitopia he's
like no I can't share with the otherwise
AIDS
as a person with health anxiety I
understand you know that you'd like
maybe not that one in particular but I'm
like waterfall it and be like all right
cool normal do you remember when people
would say like oh but it's all backwash
who is spinning back into there you know
some [ __ ] that when they go to
the water fountain they're all Oh put
them up flat I might serve one of those
people sir it's obviously like little
kids who drink water from the water
bottle they just deep-throated take all
the food in their mouth baby dumps right
back in got a water bottle is the most
disgusting thing I've ever seen in my
life
that's like 0.5% of the population but
that just like sparked a memory I
remember when Isaac was like 5 years old
or whatever he would do that so I'm like
okay baby I'm gonna teach you how to
water it's all yours giving bits of meat
back like with my child and he wanted to
drink from my water bottle he's just
gonna have to be thirsty
swallow his own spit to hydrate guys we
could go on and on with David forever
but we brought David on for a very
specific reason if you if you know David
from back in the day or if you don't
David was not always as beautiful not by
any stretch of the imagination I think
David is gorgeous now but before this
that was absolutely not the case
whatsoever to any extent David we're
still bringing in chicks non-stop the
ladies love David what is that llll dll
David I'm like David is the perfect
person to help us understand how can a
guy get out of a friendzone
so I feel like it would just be
interesting for us that they said hey
this is like how do you think I wasn't a
friend zone or what exactly throw this
out there again please for like a
million time David and I have never
dated alright
people still comment like well will
happen to David in the original Internet
[ __ ]
we did we did we did a series together
where I played a girl that he used to
have a crush on yeah for some reason
people think that must be real because
for some reason if they see Captain
America in the movie they think that
shit's [ __ ] real too they see you in
realize so you don't forget I had that
hardly I would shoot myself in the face
I would literally die if it happened I'm
like I'm good come here David your
brother that just bully son David you
would have been saying the same thing
for her too because you're like no way
in hell would I date Jeana period we're
always with like we're leading on the
David a lot but like being like in this
kind of bedroom environment I feel like
David is her older brother just bullying
we have a towel oh yeah we should put it
over his head hey what's how old let me
do your stupid-ass picture I could do
that right now in an instant we don't
wanna tell no I'm a towel originally
only a whole roll of paper towels all
right here's my question we got to get
into the mind of David the game of David
right do you yeah how do you approach
women Dave like what doing what's your
strategy oh you know what's interesting
about this like first of all didn't know
I was fat all right so I I just walked
around with a lot of confidence and I
guarantee and I guarantee you it was
probably because of a lot of like
children's programming that I thought I
just click this in my head recently so I
used to watch a [ __ ] ton of Mister
Rogers and [ __ ] right and I think like
all these like children programming that
kind of made you made me into a real
positive person that's why I love Public
Television so you know growing up too
when you're when you're when you're a
young man especially around a lot of
dudes who are sexually active they kind
of tell the story that they're that they
whenever they get a girl they just
bagged him instantly right so when they
walk up to a girl it's instant few guys
are like that but not most pictured
things so what I found out later on was
that especially when I started hanging
out with these guys when we would go out
to these clubs and I would see them I
would constantly see them swing and miss
swing and miss swing and miss so this
korie's and a lot of young guys tell
about how dope they are when they [ __ ]
or when they or when they're going for
women and they get them real quick
they're blinded by their ego yeah
they're blinded by it and they lie they
lie a lot of the times they swing and
miss all the time but there's always
just somebody that's gonna say yes that
man oh and you know what's interesting
though I feel like this is like a weird
metaphor for it but I feel like it's
almost like the way that women look at
photoshopped pictures of other women and
think oh why don't I look like that it's
like men hear these stories guys and
[Laughter]
like you know like swimsuit models and
stuff like but for guys they see they
hear these stories about these guys that
they think they caught like I've heard
like an insult community I call them
like Chad's just walk up to any woman
and get them but no these guys swing and
miss all the time but I'll tell you
about that and I hate that term
friendzone a lot because a lot of guys
use this friendzone thing when they
didn't establish the relationship
themselves in the first place so they
say that so they can feel better about
them not trying because I hate this
about dudes a lot it actually kind of
pisses me off because what there's this
really weird concept we're got it's also
that same phrase of like nice guys
finish last right the reason why I hate
that if you have to say that you're a
nice guy because I didn't get a woman
you're not really a nice guy yeah and I
just talked abouts on my podcast
originally to where I really [ __ ]
hate that phrase because nice guys who
say that they think that because they're
a nice guy that they are el-amin's
affection yeah that's dumb you are not
old [ __ ] if you're a nice guy you're
just a nice guy and you've probably met
a nice girl who was just nice to you
back so just because you treat someone
right but you're already supposed to do
it doesn't make you entitled to their
love and affection so it's like that
phrase that bothers me so much because a
lot of these dudes they don't put
themselves out there they kind of just
like sulk around the girl they support
them when they can and all of a sudden
they drop this random note where they're
like I love you oh my god I'm a woman
and I feel like you're tearing into me
right now like did I do that I'm like
I'm listening right now lis
like that okay go on go on go so you
know Muriel was talking about this too
when I had her on where she had a guy in
college that that liked her a lot she
didn't really know because he was a
really nice quiet dude and when she was
leaving college on the last day he
decides to slide her a note that was a
poem that was a poem made for her that
let him let her know how he feels and
it's like bro number one she's leaving
yeah that's the whole point of that
number two of course she's gonna be
blindsided by it because this wasn't
established in the first place when I
first started going out with Muriel she
was shocked because I liked her eyes
owned him and then I walked up to her
and so we went on a date which to me I
thought it was a day because we were
having dinner and stuff like that but
she thought we were just friends which
is kind of weird cuz we weren't really
friends and it was the first time that I
actually had a one-on-one interaction
with her so I took her out and then
before I left she kind of gave me this
whack ass little pat on the back that
good old Christian hug that Christian
hug right so no chest no body touching
nothing exactly so I looked at her I was
like oh hey by the way we're not friends
direct yeah I was like we're not friends
you gave me a friend hug I was like
we're not friends
oh [ __ ] oh my god that would that would
you know what I love that you did that
because sort of yeah - a nice but like
the first thing that I would do would be
like oh okay this guy likes me and then
I would ask myself do I like him yeah
and then if I don't like him I'm not
gonna go out on a second date with you
exactly but if I think I do like oh my
god David
that's fire everyone write that down
yeah and just just to kind of frame this
right - if you're gonna take this advice
you still have to feel out the type of
relationship that you have with the
person right did you have a good night
that you guys have chemistry you don't
just walk up to a girl and be like hey
we ain't friends it's not gonna work
like that I felt that the situation
there was a lot of we were flirting a
lot back and forth yeah you have to feel
the reciprocation cuz if there isn't any
then that's how you know you're headed
for a friend zone and the thing because
like me I had this one guy in high
school he was a neighbor of mine and we
would like walk to school together a lot
and stuff and one day out of nowhere he
just kind of tells me like hey I
actually really like you and that I can
respect because he actually told me he
didn't
obviously like he developed those
feelings he's not gonna know right off
the bat like I like you immediately know
so it's not always that that's the case
so once he ended up telling me that he
had feelings for me I had to be honest
with him and tell him well you know what
like thank you for I don't remember the
way I were today and I was probably
really shitty because I was in high
school like I don't know he was in
Spanish yeah so I ended up telling him
like you know I really don't feel the
same way towards you and I just I really
really love our friendship so you know
like can we just leave it at that
and he got like heartbroken like
shattered like he stopped talking to me
which I can understand but then I'm kind
of like that's not fair dude like we we
had a friendship yes you develop
feelings I understand that you don't
want to talk to him anymore because it
hurts you I get that but then also for
me and my experience in the whole
friendship like I feel like [ __ ] cuz
then I lost a friend that I really loved
so I don't know it's like it's a
complicated situation I think it I think
it also really has to do with pacing
like because what you were saying to
about like Mariel just getting the note
like we were at 10% and you kicked it up
to 70% so my story is so I had this guy
that I was seeing and he lived in a city
that was about 40 minutes away and I
can't ride a car not at the time but we
were like seeing each other like now and
then and like I definitely liked him but
like we we were not like all the way out
there I can't explain it so he takes me
to this open mic night at a coffee shop
and all of these people I went to high
school with are there like just people
just a lot of people that I know it's a
very busy coffee shop I would say there
was probably at least like 70 people in
there and I probably knew at least like
20 to 25 of them and he was pretty hot
so I was sitting really close to him
because I'm like you ago so just hunk of
me he was a little horny but I was like
nobody else to know that you know I was
fine and we were still feeling things
out you know I did like him but it was
just kind of ever so then he goes up to
do his set
he plays a song and it's fine he plays a
second song and it's fine and then for
his third song he said
and now I want to I want to share a poem
that I wrote for a beautiful girl that I
think I want to spend a lot more of my
life with and then he read the corneas
poem I've ever heard in my life
it was so bad it was I read do violets
are blue I love you because I'd been
sitting next to him the whole night like
everyone obviously knows that it's about
me and I completely I had to leave the
coffee shop in the middle of the poem it
really did I don't not even try I have a
vagina anymore and this was 10 years ago
I've been going to doctors ever since
but that was that was an immediate
deal-breaker for me like do not
embarrass me and do not move at a pace
that is uncomfortable interesting some
way we would have loved that beause some
women would have been like oh my god
it's so romantic
if it was reciprocated dude no would you
all personally no I would I'm just
saying they're like it's just not meant
for you this day to this day David you
know when you had this memory that's I
know those memories that just make you
go but I'm like but it was interesting
because this guy was on the right track
and he [ __ ] it up like Ricky didn't
yeah you didn't me you write like yo
trees arrested Oh public displays of
affection are risk you know they make
movies about that [ __ ] where the dude
decides to do a public display of
affection for this woman and it
embarrasses her don't do that don't do
that or maybe ask a question like hey do
you like public displays of affection
I'm cringing is thinking about you just
sitting there having this guy read this
poem out loud and it's making my body I
was there David light skinned my skin
there was a line about my chocolatey
skin I'm not [ __ ] kidding David but
like in a beautiful way I'm surprised he
didn't call me a Nubian goddess yeah it
was it was it was really bad is real bad
okay carry on carry on oh yeah I don't
like that I feel I feel really bad
inside right now I feel violated my
toast my turn I feel like you probably
get that [ __ ] no David I was about
to ask you know I'm like well we David
and I have witnessed a friendzone
relationship of like climbing to
friendship friendzone friends and they
actually met each other yeah I can so we
went on this like fun little trip
together
now it'll not be named where we went but
it was a fun little trip overseas I saw
these two the interaction of two guys
that were friendzone so hard fighting
for your attention stop laughing
I could not stop because so cool Aires
when guys like Jeana they fall head over
heels and they try so oh really
you're the quintessential girl that I
think a lot of young guys wanted right
the girl who likes games very hot very
pretty great you know sense of humor and
so when they see of two humors water
chest is very true you were like you
were like early 20s dream in celle dream
dude so like when I saw him selling my
bathwater and my toe clippings I don't
give a [ __ ] his picture you butt ass
naked dude all right so like they the
way they would interact with you is so
funny like if you had told them to chop
off their feet and sew it to their ear
they would in an instant just like how
quickly you can get some food delivered
to your door with what oh my god dad
think you could get it delivered with
- - I heard that or - about the story -
tell you all about it
ding-dong [ __ ] long day at work how
about some food and you can have some
food with door - not to mention you can
use our special code at the end of this
ad for five dollars off last night I was
real sad and I don't want to get up out
the bed so I got on my phone and I used
my door - app and got guess what I got
what you want
ramen ramen ramen what kind of run
straight to my door from door - yes girl
yes black garlic it was good oh yeah go
on
sounds good it was real good mmm and you
didn't have to get out of like or you
did have to get out of the bed to get
it's right never get out of me with door
- door - connects you to your favorite
restaurants in the city and ordering is
incredibly easy just use the door - app
choose what you want to eat and a Dasher
will bring it to you anywhere you are
yeah they have over thirty three hundred
and forty thousand amazing restaurant
what yeah three hundred forty thousand
delivering in over three thousand three
hundred cities delivered in over three
hundred in all 50 states and including
Canada so even Canada that's right local
- goes local go twos or choose from your
favorite chains like Chipotle or the
Cheesecake Factory
you can literally order anything that
you want everything I'm one cheese cake
ladies and germs don't worry about
dinner let dinner come to you with Dora
- so right now our listeners can get
five dollars off your first order of 15
or more when you download the door - app
and into the promo code big move that's
five dollars off your first order when
you download the door - app from the App
Store and into the promo code big mood
don't forget that's big mood for five
dollars off so you're telling me they
will deliver something loose they'll do
something nice to us uh-huh and don't
even expect me anything back nothing Wow
nothing Wow they'll even give me five
dollars off Wow
that's right go off girl's not kind of
man you know what happens when an Intel
hits on you oh you gotta keep calm
true they say it takes two months to
form a habit mmm and if you're making a
resolution this year that can feel like
a long time to wait to see results right
really with calm all takes us five
minutes a day to feel better calmer and
ready to face whatever this year's knows
that you how does it do that so calm is
a number one a four sleep relaxation and
meditation and you know I cannot sleep
with a [ __ ] ever oh my god am I supposed
to custom this I don't care
Keep Calm come on I sleep stories which
are like bedtime stories for adults and
adult bedtime story they to these every
single night they're read by celebrities
really know that I know I don't remember
who it was but I open it up and I had a
celebrity read me to sleep Morgan
Freeman oh they can help you fall into a
deep natural sleep in minutes and
stories are narrated by iconic voices
like levar burton Oh Reading Rainbow
mm-hmm and Nick Offerman right mustache
right okay they also have soothing music
from artists like Sam Smith guided
meditations breathing exercises so much
more and now if you go to come dot-com
sebastien mood you'll get a limited time
offer of 40% off a calm premium
subscription which includes hundreds of
hours of programming over sixty million
people use calm David you should be one
of the millions yeah all right for
listeners of the show comm is offering a
special limited time promotion of again
40% off of calm premium if you got a
calm calm slash mood that's 40% off so
get started today that's again Bose calm
calm huh / mood that's right I dunno so
now tell us Oh double friends I like it
more when David tells to this well I
mean I've got so many friends own
stories for you because of this girl
it's hilarious there was a guy that we
actually knew listen before we didn't
get into that
like I remember this dude we were I saw
him make this special meal right it was
like broiled salmon all this Japanese
food in this little bento box right and
I was like what the [ __ ] is going on
this [ __ ] is like a Japanese
chef and he starts wrapping wrapping it
up in a nice little little present gift
thing right I'm like who is he dropping
this off to and then he takes these cute
little cartoons and he has made of her
and him [ __ ] like glues it onto the
thing yeah that's up in a bow you want
to talk about friendzone [ __ ]
that's when she's getting like door -
meals made by this boy straight-up door
- that calm / mood delivered to her
comes and delivers it - in the morning
bounces but you know what's funny - I
bet you Jeana just said I'm so hungry
right now I really wish I had some
salmon thirsty though because I remember
this one time when you came over and you
ended up sleeping on his bed I'm just
taking a nap and he was like I'm a
sleepy [ __ ] and I'll sleep in anybody
off in downtown LA and Skid Row I will
find a mattress with nap on if I'm a
tired
I believe it don't mean [ __ ] like but
you know to go back to the kind of just
the guys that are in these position it's
so funny because you're saying like
David was saying that they mope around
they're like oh my god I can't get her
I'm so sad and like we're really blowing
Gina's ego up here but I mean I have to
like pull it full circle this is a
beautiful woman that's hilarious plays
video games do pretty confident popular
online has like a great or address as
well as smells nice you know all the
[ __ ] and like kind of hyping her up so
much but when you have a woman that the
caliber and quality of her is really up
there
you can't just sit there and beat
yourself up and say I'm not good enough
cuz I'm too much of a female then go up
to him
NOLA but I also imagine how many guys
are vying for her attention and you're
not even calculating that into what
you've been doing to try and then you
come back to yourself and you say wow I
really suck and I'm like no dude you're
basically fighting for like Gwyneth
Paltrow when there's a hundred other
dudes fighting also - I didn't give you
like Angelina that's why I gave you no
one win also - you probably just [ __ ]
whack do ya like you just yeah okay and
we know who he is right yeah it was so
funny though cuz I would be better all
the time like I was already dating
someone for like two years and David
knew but I kept it private nobody knew
and he kept on going you should give him
a chance but it was just like you know
he's a sweet guy it's just he doesn't
dis corny and also - what I didn't like
that he didn't which is what these type
of dudes do a lot is like the stories
that he tells about you was different
from the actual yeah he would he would
say stuff like late it kind of like what
I just like yeah exactly so he's so
narcissistic that he has like his own
yeah I think that's why he think he
thought he had a chance with you because
in his head he's up there with you and
in terms of caliber but he actually
wasn't so he would even phrase it in the
sense of like yeah we're like kind of
dating that's what he would say when he
would say this like inside I'm dying
laughing
I can't I can't say anything though it
was so funny because this guy like he
just really was so wrapped up in his own
little fantasy he was refusing to live
in the real world so when we kind of all
stopped hanging out with him yeah and
you guys told me what he really was I
was like what I've never seen that and
then that's you're the one he told me
like dude you have no idea how different
he acts around you and I had compared to
yes yeah I had no clue so then um I
living is like I never
gave the notion of hey I'm interested in
you like ever in his bed you are your
bed your bed your bed I bet you took
that man with you so oh my gosh she's in
my bed
it was delusional really every time she
got her heart broken I would see this
girl like a sad puppy outside my door
[ __ ] come inside and then she would
just come over she would sleep she was
sleep over and I'm like cry your [ __ ]
woes away not once that that show you
know this was in my bed three days to
cry then get the [ __ ] out this guy he's
like he calls up a friend and gets right
up close your knees like oh that's
snoring yeah that's a miss Gina darling
with you sleeping behind and then like a
little tiny tag the one that took a
picture of my girlfriend sleeping
yeah and pretended that he was sleeping
with her bro like so the other one was
friendzone hard too and it was shitty
because if you start off on the guise of
hey yeah I just wanna be friends and
then throw on something like more it's
like dude that's kind of [ __ ] up you
know you should have been honest from
the friar well if he did have those
feelings in the beginning because I
wouldn't blame him if he developed them
later and then realized it that's
another thing so what happened with
another creepy thing so um they he and
this girl she's good friend of mine
we're driving down from Seattle I think
and I was out of town he said yo can we
crash at your place I guess sure let's
see like that go ahead you can crash my
place and I guess the whole time he was
telling her
uh yeah Gina has a an air mattress you
know so we don't sleep together blah
blah no I didn't he didn't ask it so
they get here at like 2:00 in the
morning like oh no they forgot to set
out the air mattress Oh
there she repeated loser and then he's
like okay fine I'll just take the bed
made her sleep on the floor oh I bet you
that was like a little tactic for him
like yeah yeah she'll crawl in bed yeah
so the next morning he wakes up early
goes runs and errands he wakes her up
and says hey you can go sleeping better
when I run errands he comes back she's
still asleep he moves the blanket so her
leg is showing takes a picture of her
sleeping and then climbs into bed and
takes a selfie of her creeps one of our
mutual guy friends and says bro
dump some come today yeah you don't
understand that kind of mentality
because it's like if you're gonna be
putting this much effort to impress
other people like why can't you put that
amount of effort into actually getting
the girl zactly
because guys like that don't like
rejection oh that was him huh yeah I
didn't they were drooling all over you
too
III like watching it too because in my
mind I'm thinking like what the [ __ ] are
you guys thinking dude nothing is going
to happen like nothing is going to
happen at all and and the weird thing is
it goes back to that thing of they take
kindness as flirting yes not flirting
flirting it's like you know what it is
it to me I think that like sometimes
there sometimes these there certain guys
they're so insecure that they're looking
for a sign and they're so desperate for
a sign that they might take that
kindness or they might take you know a
response to their message as a sign like
okay I'm in and they take a little tiny
bit and they'd say like oh this is
enough for me this is enough well let's
keep going let's keep pushing it and
then they're building this reality and
their mind that doesn't exist whereas
like when we're here in the present
we're like no I just you know liked your
DM all right you know I didn't even
respond to it yo we're in February now
have you kept up with your new year's
resolutions I haven't because some of us
had a news resolution to work out and
then we're like what my schedules crazy
I can't fit it into my schedule I can't
guess what open fits got you covered
because you can actually work out
anywhere anytime with their streaming
service and you can access some of the
best trainers in the world right there
at your fingertips you don't even need
to leave
your workplace our home you have a right
there on your phone or your TV they have
amazing trainers and classes it's super
simple you can access anywhere anytime
and there's results you can see which I
think is the most important part for me
I love targeting different things at
different times so I love that you can
just choose from a variety of workouts
and like I like the barre class and then
I sometimes I want to take it easy into
yoga
and sometimes I want that strength
training I want someone to like tell me
to crush it and have to crush my goals
and then I'm not doing enough work like
that stuff too so open finish change the
way I workout and with our code mood you
can join me on a fitness journey
personalized just for you and right now
our listeners get a 14-day free trial
membership - yeah - - for last week's -
open fit when you text mood - 50 50 50
try them for free or your money back
it's entirely risk-free so what do you
have to lose besides weight and you'll
get full access to open fit all the
workouts a nutrition guide totally free
for 14 days
again just sex mood - 50 5050 disclaimer
Sandage standard message and data rates
may apply so check with your carrier and
then the super toxic ones are the ones
who afterwards when you tell them you're
not interested yeah thank you you led me
on like bro right and it's okay to like
shoot your shot but you know when you
get rejected it just is what it is bro
just take the L and move on I don't take
it so personally it like if somebody
doesn't feel you who the [ __ ] cares move
on you're going to die from it yeah let
me just put it in perspective there are
people out there who have been married
and their spouses passed away and they
have to find somebody else that they
love I'm pretty sure if they could find
somebody so can you if you get rejected
by a stranger so you'll be fine dude
a lot of these dudes they talk this huge
[ __ ] game they act like they're mr.
tough guy but when a girl just says no
to them they crumble it's like yeah my
god and they take it so much it's like
there's something wrong with me
I'm unlovable and they have this
self-fulfilling prophecy I something's
wrong with me but in reality like it you
might be going to your phase you may be
more insecure than usual you may be
codependent at that period of time and
then your behavior stem from that state
of mind that you're in and I can't
express enough how much it's a state of
mind it's not you it's not who you truly
are
but when you let these little situations
affect you and you take those on well
now they now become personality traits
you let a small situation go from a mood
to like a depression - now it's a
personality trait and you've taken that
on yourself and shot the second arrow
girl yet that's true we talked about
this tip and I be getting real spiritual
yeah you know when I say this - I also
say it in a sense of like I'm not saying
is like I'm the guy who never did that
is just that's the younger version of
myself and so I get like heated and
passionate about this topic because I
see a side of myself that I hated when I
was younger and I had to choose to
change that yes when I first was when my
very first girlfriend I was like
obsessed with this girl which I don't
even [ __ ] know why actually I dunno
why is because when I played yes she was
my very first girlfriend and for her I
had a crush on her from my freshman year
all the way till senior year of high
school
and then when we finally got together
after we broke up we were off and on for
about a year or so and there was a
moment where I realized is that I
started defining who I was and who and
everything that I loved about myself
based on what this person told me that I
was right so if she said I was a good
person I'm a good person if I'm a good
guy
I'm a good guy but I would never think
about that for myself so I let somebody
else to find Who I am right and so that
was the moment where I to take a step
back and be like dude you're a [ __ ]
loser okay you David you're a [ __ ]
loser man like and I remember that
moment - it was this time where so she
and I went to the same Community College
together after I left UC Riverside and
came back and she and I went to this
place called consumerist River College
and so she said something that hurt my
feelings
a lot but it was true she looked at me
she goes she's never said this to me
before she goes you're kind of annoying
and I was like what as I show you kind
of annoying me and I think it was
because I was so [ __ ] thirsty
right after she broke up with me and I
remember I went home and I was like the
[ __ ] does she mean I'm annoying and I
started like looking back at the way I
was behaving around her and I was like
you walk around and you talked to her
like you don't have a [ __ ] backbone
dude you are annoying and then from that
moment I started like shifting my
behavior right it was like when I talked
to women now I have to like myself I
have to be confident enough and if a
woman doesn't like me she doesn't like
me they're not oh I don't they don't owe
me their affection so for me at that
point that was a huge turn
so when I say these things to like guys
out there and I see that I'm very
passionate about it is because I'm only
talking to my younger self I hated that
moment in my life like looking back and
saying you get to define how I feel
about myself I'll never let that happen
again I think it's like it's very common
for men and women to draw their
confidence externally because now it
depends on did you get a raise at work
did you have a good day does this person
like you whereas when your confidence
comes internally it is literally not
achievable if I never got a compliment
on my Instagram ever again I will kill
myself beause it's so interesting so
what I'm hearing from this conversation
is like you know for a guy to be liked
by a like a woman there's a myriad of
things but what we're hearing
reoccurring is assertiveness confidence
and not being [ __ ] creepy yeah hey
and I always want to remind people if
you're a date like guys out there really
if you are dating somebody or you're
looking at someone you're interested in
them and you are under 30 calm the [ __ ]
down
like seriously calm the [ __ ] down that
respect too is like the respect for
yourself as a man to know where you
stand and know what you want know what
you like like what David discovered and
then also respecting the girl you're
chasing after and respecting like oh she
just doesn't like me then okay cool yeah
and I'm like don't be a [ __ ] creep
and have like all these malicious
intentions like that guy that you
brought up Gina where like he's crawling
into bed with this chick like not even
knowing and did she have a boyfriend to
like this week react so it's just like
don't don't do that like respected her
if you're if you like her then you
should be respecting and respect
yourself look this mama say if you are
under 30 get on tinder and go [ __ ] a
couple of fives you know just so you're
feeling good about yourself move through
the day like stop going for sevens calm
down just go for five and then go to
work get your get your salary up get
like feel confident in your work go buy
a [ __ ] house and we will come running
yeah it's like it's like dealing what
you can deal with in your own lane and
like everything else will fall in place
yes everything will fall in place like
seriously and by the time you're 30 and
you got this nice college
have y'all ever walked into a dude's
house and it's really nice and you're
like oh my god I just dropped an egg
yeah seriously yeah get get a house I'm
serious get a house also it's also too
like you got to stop like defining your
manhood and your Worth based on how many
women you [ __ ] I went I went out one
night a few weeks ago with some friends
and there's this guy who just went
through a breakup so this other guy
friend this other guy friend is very
like castanet wide you know and the
whole time he's like alright we gotta
get her boy laid we gotta get her boy
laid all right so and then like the
whole night just what that one right
there go go get him go just like bro
chill and he goes and like bored for
where he goes we gotta get our boy ahold
tonight and he just brought me he just
views women as object yeah and he
brought with him and I looked at the
girl like really what this guy like you
should have what this guy and he ruined
our night because everything was like we
gotta help him go over there
wingman him don't go like yeah we're
gonna leave like it's just it's really
weird and I think it's it's just I think
they're starting to shift a little more
specifically I remember I told the story
because I lost my virginity when I was
18 and when I was 8 alright the [ __ ]
dick was terrible that I gave so I lost
my virginity when I was 18 but all my
homies lost in Virginia when they were
like 14 even 13 oh right so when I said
18 and I put that story out on YouTube
they're like well you lost it kind of
early Wow I was like woah what like I
guess it ain't raisin they're losing
something I guess they might be in
decent areas but they're losing their
virginity a little later and that's okay
too
because like when I was younger I kind
of hated that I didn't lose my virginity
yet and so it was kind of this weird
thing of like I kind of just wanted to
[ __ ] so I could say I that's the reason
why I like why I lost my virginity was
cuz I don't I hated being the last
virgin in my friend group sometimes and
it's a weird pressure to have man dude
you got a long life ahead of you dude
there's a lot of [ __ ] out there dude I
still know a 28 year old virgin he has a
girlfriend for two years and it's real
cute she's rough man
didn't handle that like you don't drop
this white flag you gonna drop them
drawers wouldn't happen so you're one of
those people while you like the guy was
like I can't have sex until we're
married you're like we'll see about I
want to just show up but [ __ ] but you
ass out oh here we go put it in that's
cool try again tomorrow
yeah extra lip gloss on every day you
get to the point where like you don't
waste time anymore i legit told a guy
once just drop it and see what you're
working with first and what were you
telling me that I'm a grower not a
shower just tap it a couple of times
just tap it just pelvic thrust three
times and they're so in love with her
that it just immediately raised it he's
like distracting you for like ten
seconds just so get a little chub they
just just about it like Japanese
charcoal no I hate the term friendzone -
recently I got a tattoo of matching
tattoos with my best friend from high
school it's a guy and then all the
comments were like a super friend zone
r.i.p to our homie friend zone like like
shut the [ __ ] up dude
I think like people who believe in
friend zones are the ones who go into
like a French like relationship with
someone and just lie about it like after
I pee to him for real though hate like
I'm a guy like hate is like you're
really cool like I want to be friends
with you and then you actually become my
friend you're like [ __ ] you and I'm just
like [ __ ] you you know like yes so wrong
to have platonic friends of the opposite
sex I heard I heard a metaphor before
claiming to be that you're in a friend
zone it's like going to a job interview
not getting the job they hire someone
else and you're just hanging around the
lobby yeah I heard that guy like oh man
you know I'm a good employee too you
know stuff like that and it's [ __ ]
weird you know like you're not hired for
a reason and you're just like wait and
then you make friends with a manager and
the manager thinks you're really a
friend and then eventually when you
don't give him a job you all pissed on
who you know what the really red ones
are the guys that they the guys that
like are waiting for you to get out of a
relationship and they're like alright I
know she'll break up with him any time
I'll just I'll just wait I'll just wait
like no just
my friend what are you waiting for right
well you know what it's really great
though for those friends that do become
more and then you end up having a
beautiful relationship to the point that
it leads to you guys getting so
expensive to it they are you know the
most expensive part of a wedding is the
wedding planner right now I've hired a
wedding planner for my wedding in Paris
it was very expensive very beautiful
they did create but if I would have
known about Zola which is a online
wedding planning service my pocket would
still it would be fatter so engagement
season aka the most popular time to pop
the question is in full-swing know like
six people who got engaged less [ __ ]
two weeks yeah so it's actually like
starting Thanksgiving and spanning all
the way through Valentine's Day Oh
engagements dude also when you give her
that ring give her a little gift card
for Zola mm yeah exactly and then you
will also be saving money cuz you know
once you guys get married you're joining
you're gonna keep her from getting that
expensive wedding planner and just be
like hey babe I already got a Zola it's
fine yeah exactly
so why Zola because Zola makes wedding
planning easier and less stressful with
wedding websites registry invites and a
guest list manager all in one place so
you can get really organized and so they
offer free wedding website design so
it's easy to create your site within
minutes you can add a custom URL or a
password protection and so they have the
highest rated registry of all they
register or you could register for gifts
experiences and honeymoon funds you can
add gifts from other stores or sync
existing registry so it's super super
organized so Zola has helped 1 million
couples get married and they'll help you
too so make sure to go to Zola comm
slash big mood today and use promo code
save 50 to get 50% off your save the
dates you can also get a free
personalized paper sample before you
purchase that's 50% off
save the dates at Zola com / big mood
promo code save
dee tell Muriel I look at my mistakes oh
yeah you're engaged I was like don't let
that convict move and it's a prepare for
your wedding I think it's time to
develop some healthy habits yeah with
noon oh yes with new guys new
missfantastic it's not only just one of
those like wellness and weight loss apps
where they're like okay here are the
5000 squats you need to do today and you
need to do them otherwise you're never
gonna lose this way
they actually motivate you with a
personal trainer that will message you
in the morning and be like good morning
Bo's did you do your workout and I'm
like oh my god I'm so sorry no I haven't
done it yet yeah I'll do it right now
it's great they will actually be on you
about achieving your goals but not just
beyond you they'll also support you noon
can help you eat better to feel better
have more energy and actually start
enjoying exercise which is the hardest
part for me I've been sitting behind my
computer playing video games for 15
years why would I ever need to exercise
about changing that mentality yes girl
and now that I'm getting older the body
is not what it once was
tell me about it that's still nice
though oh yeah oh my god girls stop
thank you new okay based on psychology
new teaches you why you do the things
that you specifically do and it empowers
you with the tools to break the bad
habits and replace them with with other
ones you actually talk about what
motivates you what's stopping you what's
preventing you and they personalize your
plan to help you it's based on a
cognitive behavioral approach and uses
personalized courses to help you reach
your specific goals and everyone's busy
we get it and that's why new doesn't
take up too much of your time they only
ask for 10 minutes a day you have 24
hours of the day you only need to give
them 10 minutes you're assigned a goal
specialist and matched it with a
community of other numers so there's
always support system and people going
to the same exact things you are so it's
the perfect time to make that step
towards healthier habits sign up for
your child today at noon and that's Noom
comm slash big movie big moon big moon
so visit new mom slash big moon to start
your trial today become a numero neucom
eyelash big mood big mood
in oh oh em and I'm Nancy that's right
Oh Oh
ocean ocean em in oom calm there's like
all right now that that's over you guys
don't know any words huh Michael what is
the M for the for the military dinging
Anna yeah you know guys I want Foxtrot I
actually want to talk about it we've
talked a lot about the personality
aspects of it and not saying that we're
vain or anything but I almost want to
talk about like a vain physical oh can I
can I just give the advice for some
couple of dudes right
real talk there's a few things that you
could fix right off the jump just by the
way deodorant oh well there's that too
look look good haircut clean kicks nice
jeans yep yeah that's the first three
things that you should fix it right off
the jump this is the one thing that can
make a guy go from like five to six is a
whole point yeah it is a whole point if
you're get in that like [ __ ]
Vietnamese buzz cut six dollar haircut
cut that [ __ ] out go to a barber get a
nice [ __ ] fade wash your ass give
some a nice kick some nice fitting jeans
and you could just wear a regular like
plain tea on top and you'll look yeah
yeah honestly like okay you could be a
straight up for all right and if you get
the good haircut and the good jeans you
instantly turn up to a six and dog a six
I could date it six
you know the personality in there is C a
seven you got a house all right eight do
you love me you're a good smell good too
guys
oh okay I we've talked about this before
on the show guys
shower put on light scent or unscented
deodorant acts please yes never s if
you're your second thirteen you're
wearing acts
I will bully you to death when I smell
like a 40 year old man smells like old
spice I'm a come on bro get it together
like nothing so Muriel I so I used to
wear Cologne a lot you know but when she
and I got together she would be like how
come you don't wear Cologne when we go
out right so now I only wear Cologne
when she and I go out now cuz I don't
know why but that's that one little
thing that she's at Babbo cuz like for
her she wanted to feel special and
important where it's like this is safe
for me kind of thing yeah I think so so
for me I'm just like oh cool I don't
have to put on the Cologne in the whole
scent game thing all the time I just
have to do it for her now I'm like cool
because I used to always smell on point
I remember yeah you used to come into I
give you a good morning hug and I'm like
David all right look don't be the where
my hug actual physical man if you see a
guy there's always getting hugged by
girls it's cuz he smells good like she
yeah and I bury my face into his chest I
don't care if he has breasts I will bury
my face in his chest if he smells good
if I come over and I hug a group of
friends and you notice oh I didn't get
hugged even when I make eye contact with
you do not reason where's my hug because
then you're putting me in a weird
[ __ ] spot yeah you know and before
it'd be nice now I'm just like I don't
know go find it somewhere else like just
go for it like you're a group of like 4
guys Gina comes in and hugs all three
and then when she looks at you and just
goes everybody gets a hug and you're
like just one finger it's funny too
because I don't think guys know that
girls can also sense especially if
they're not attracted to you when you
have an ulterior motive when you hug
them or touch oh yeah oh my god yeah
because you as a girl listen you're not
being [ __ ] sly when you hug us and
you press the chest a little extra like
harder cuz I know you're trying to feel
my [ __ ] tits stop doing that that's
[ __ ] creepy I remember in high school
this would happen so much
friendship hug I'm not gonna like put my
titties on you and be like yeah friend
no what the [ __ ] that's weird is just
like oh it's a nice hug but then when
you actually move your hand like behind
like you know politician hug the creepy
politician it's like a one-armed I'm
like when they reach around all the way
to your side boob and they squeeze the
side boob like oh yeah do it on camera
and like people just do ariana grande
with that or when they they come in and
they give you that hug and they use
their fingers to start hiking your shirt
up and then they unclasp your bra strap
and then have been through all of it
yeah creepy men since I was nine years
old
all right like oh [ __ ] over here since I
was nine been hit no oh you know you
know pass the bra straps yeah yeah just
remove the hand you don't need a slope
which is my ass you can hug we're a
guide you start it from your upper back
oh my god yeah absolutely like Holland
David David come here y'all so they had
to go some thank you let's go let's go
got a fat [ __ ] ass though do it I
still started one I didn't even know on
that Instagram post where you just kind
of stuck it out the first thing I said
that's good to be all that we're gonna
that's a picture we'll just chat about
that [ __ ] ass
like if I get my ass done i'ma show the
not a picture of you like legit but like
you could tell who the girls are just by
a silhouette because of her ass yeah she
got this tiny little body and it just
goes hello
yeah [ __ ] got cake though - she does
Nick you just wheel up my ass it sounds
like a laptop closes oh when we we saw
when we went to the spa and I saw all of
you naked Jess looks like a porcelain
green yeah yeah also her her stuff
because like she's she's more mature
like her body like it comes out yeah
right it sure it sure does guess what
guess what is the biggest nipples in the
group the pinkest guess the pinkest one
guess who
somebody really Jess nope well hers
wanted to hers the second Pincus listen
David luck to you I always be to your
left something about it I sold it we saw
and I had to tweet about it immediately
I think you have pink nipples yeah damn
so like everything is black but somebody
uploaded a fake video of me and the
nipples are Brown and I was like nice
try dude
yeah I think it's the same color as my
lips I wonder what your lips do guys
care about the car the nipples probably
like a darker nipple and some guys
probably like a lighter
I think people the size of the areola
what is your preference of areola let us
know below in the comments or you just
send it to me in a DM baby do you like
pepperoni so you like salami is your
like boloney's no it's funny like when
you when you're [ __ ] around the girl
and you see something that shocks you
it's it's cut you gotta play it off like
right when I saw that bigger oh my god
to the same man but you know what it is
though it's like it's because porn kind
of [ __ ] up your perception yes realize
it everybody got a different looking
[ __ ] in a different looking tit so
that's a lot of surface covers more than
I expected because I've seen big areolas
which I like but then it's like my god
yeah have you seen them visible Wow when
there's no area you can't see the areola
but there's just nipple what never seen
you have never seen in visited before
girls bart has just like yeah or but
sometimes no areola it's just the same
color as their skin is in the nipple
yeah Oh Google and visit nipple I've
seen that bullseye actually go in Oh
inverted what Mattel toy when you're
dating somebody for a long time and they
love you so much that they love like
everything that you were like once
insecure up so like there's a girl out
there with inverted nipples and she's
gonna date somebody one day they love
her so much that it's like that's
[ __ ] cute you're like I love that the
human body is all different too
yeah not not everything you know that's
I think that was like the biggest
biggest thing that I learned because in
porn you kind of just see like this
general vagina all the time and there's
like a few different vaginas here and
there but when you start [ __ ]
different girls it's like oh look at
that one yeah different I remember the
first time I saw a hook dick it's it's
like like our meaty like it is like and
I mean this this thing was that so
intense curve which way did it hook I'm
it went in there like yeah it's to hit
your g-spot you don't know where my
g-spot it is Tim I said this before
multiple times but his dick curves to
the left so he hasn't let me know this
guy was straight like just what should
mark like I didn't know what it was it
was it curved up damn I feel good all
right it was like yeah it literally
looks like a sex toy like did us but I
was so I had never seen anything like it
before and it like I wasn't like oh
there's gonna be fun I was just like wow
what are you gonna do with that
you have to enter at a different angle
to like he has to start here in the turn
and spin and spin me around and you guys
never seen me like like body things that
you would they caught you off-guard like
I used today I have always dated a lot
of white boys and from Virginia and so
like like none of them ended like ever
been with a black girl anything so
that's the first time that when I took
my shirt off they were like oh those
look like those look like other nipples
I've seen I'm like yeah [ __ ] yeah well
you're a rarity yeah yeah I guess they
thought from porn that it was gonna be
like dark and they were so disappointed
I would Michael was a [ __ ] Barbie
doll one guy who had two holes in the
top of what was the hole how was that
possible and the skin underneath didn't
like completely attachment there's
another hole wait we were digging for us
sometimes I just like put things in
there like a Pierce oh no it doesn't
hurt though like a tie a little bow I'm
weird
sorry huh yeah I'm confused I mean you
need a thing instead of one hole in his
dick there were two so okay same you
were playing alright okay the skin on
the head um a part of it didn't attach
completely so it's just like a little a
little tiny hole like a loop like you
could see through the hole
and so you would he would just let you
stick things in there then you have a
lot of control over your men dude that's
not a second hole in there like you're
just gonna stick like a little cookie
crumb in there lutely not so strange you
do you demand a lot of things from the
guys that you're with like when it comes
to sex uh no not really
um I've converted some to like my kinks
and stuff um but you guys are just
naturally very comfortable around me cuz
I'm a very like openly sexual person you
don't you Kenny ones young I don't yup
anyone's young like one guy I was dating
he goes
yeah I think I kind of want to try ass
play
and I'm like mm yes treasure chest in
below deep into the ocean absolutely
what if I'm Ariel wanted it because you
love her you want to make her happy
what does she wanted to play you good
Disneyland to make her happy would you
do that what if she started I don't plan
with your but I don't like anal sex
I think anal sex is [ __ ] I don't
either you know what it's because like
well first of all poop comes out of
there and also to the only one time that
I did it was the girl's idea and I found
out that the pressure is only at the the
the ring the ring area and there's whack
I was like why even do this [ __ ] there's
a made for a dick what about just the
the ring would they would they would you
let a girl play ring around the Rosie
I'm just very like openly new and
usually do it
at least she at least he kind of like
forewarned you about it one of my
friends from Virginia she told me about
how she hooked up with this guy in New
York in a bathroom he'd picked her up
and put her on the sink in a bathroom in
New York City
she'd never met him before yeah and they
started like hooking up and then he peed
on her no you can't just dump that on
some interface and and I can't have you
yeah and she was like oh my god like so
like jarred by it and then he was like
what he was like you seem like the type
of chick that would be well she's still
texted him back Robert Kelly no
no man 12 was she
it was not break so did she think he was
about to nut and then instead it was
urine hey there's the most offensive
thing ever dude she's just like her eyes
closed like peeing or him saying usually
make the type of girl that would I
rather the insults than the actual yeah
[ __ ] you know what about your live
after that yeah like if you have a kinky
you gotta discuss it first like I'm not
just gonna in the middle sex choke the
[ __ ] out of me you know I'm gonna talk
to you about it first you know so you
don't get freaked out and like think
that yeah you might yeah catch Kate wait
and that's funny too because some guys
like they're really into a thing and it
maybe it's a little weird and they don't
have the ability to communicate that so
just do it yeah
it's a lot for a guy to say like hey I
wanna I want to do but play it's hard
for that and so instead maybe they'll
just like I don't know try to guide you
there do something but like it's okay to
talk about before I do that it's like
when you guys are watching a movie on
Sun he just has his hand over your
shoulder you start grabbing the back
here I like the guy that I am in a
relationship with now like very early on
we discussed what we liked and liked
what we didn't like and I remember like
there was one time we were literally
having sex and like you know doing like
going down on each other and stuff like
that and we were like asking like do you
like that do you like this and and it
was just the first lesson second time
that we asked and then it's okay for it
to be awkward two times on every time
you have sex has to be a porno scene it
really doesn't but then after the two
times that we did that now we literally
have the best sex ever and it's been
that way for two years and just getting
better and after a while you can
actually after sex ask so anything that
you want to add yeah what was your
favorite thing about that and it has a
survey at a Google Doc and that's all
anyone who you date and then he had
asked like he asked me one day because I
always ask what was your favorite that
like sometimes right on the ass and the
one dude he was like well what was your
favorite thing and I was like I liked
when you dirty toy and now he
I think a lot of guys need a girl to
kind of say things that they like and
dislike because a lot of guys like I
said it's that pressure when they're
younger to expect to know everything
especially when it comes to sex and
they'll lie about [ __ ] so like for me
the biggest life lesson I ever had was
this one Filipino girl that I dated and
I remember after we had sex I was like
how was it she was like would you be mad
right and then from then on she just
kind of listed stuff that she liked that
it dislike it hurt my ego a little bit
but [ __ ] knows yeah and then
from then on I started asking you know
and then we started having conversations
about things because at that point you
just don't really know as sometimes
girls feel guilty for making a guy feel
bad so they'll just have wack [ __ ] so
you got to get yours exactly she was she
was a good life lesson because also good
to like take notes but then also don't
don't be so in your head because you're
like oh like even even though you're
asking yourself in your own head like oh
am i doing it right like that you you
can totally read into that and like the
eggshell like stepping on eggshells kind
of thing happens yeah a little like - I
mean here's the [ __ ] stories about
guys who like choke - hearted [ __ ] okay
beat my ass with a tire iron
I like how I Jesse are you very
demanding in sectionals no not really
get a [ __ ] fire hydrants wash you
down okay so we've talked about
physically what we really like in a man
we've talked to we've touched on
mentally what we really like and I kind
of just want to like round it all up
here and actually we've kind of like
brushed over some stuff sexually too but
like so far I hear confidence
I hear what else do we say don't be
creepy I was back learn how to read if
read somebody learn how to read yeah
like if the girl is just like okay yeah
and then you just keep on [ __ ]
talking to her and she's not asking
questions you okay cool walk away dude
yeah it's in stop looking for a sign yes
ask a question ask something that if you
feel it's okay to ask something direct
ask something direct and there's
different tiers of questions you could
be asking like like you could be saying
like are we gonna [ __ ] tonight or you
could be like oh would you feel
comfortable like going out with me
one-on-one like there's different level
also don't go out like don't [ __ ]
focus and go out for the sole purpose of
trying to get girls oh yeah happen it'll
happen but like if every time you go out
like I gotta get a girl I gotta get a
girl I gotta get a girl like people can
smell that desperation and they're seen
Assaf yeah mmm I can smell it from a
mile away it's gross it's super gross
and confidence it's a big thing to Vegas
I've went on a couple dates with a guy
who's like tall beautiful nice car good
like living whatever and just lacked
confidence like if you're six foot two
you can still carry yourself like a 5
foot zero and not there's nothing wrong
with five guys alright short guys need
love too and if they have good
confidence they're [ __ ] fantastically
there have been some short guys were
like confidence oh my god like there's
so there's one that popped into my mind
immediately he was like he was probably
like 5-1 and like if you carry yourself
like a seven-foot - yeah I met him at
Hooters and like he like I was working
at Hooters
this story is weird yeah yeah
oh that the Keebler Elf Factory but you
know what though - with confidence I
feel like so often the number one answer
when you ask a woman what do you look
for in a guy is he's got to be funny
like that's what people always say but I
think a big portion of that is like not
just the synthy of humor but also the
confidence that comes with a sense of
humor because if he's not funny what is
he doing he's asking you do you like the
food
what do you like to do for fun and that
feels weird when a guy can turn a
question like that into a joke we like
that because it feels carefree it feels
comfortable it's taking our mind off of
some of the situation
so like and yes add some humor in there
but we love the confidence that comes
with the sense of humor - yeah right
thank guys need to take notes man y'all
need it if you're young this is a good
podcast for you guys take things with
the wood like a grain of salt - because
I'm saying like because I think
sometimes - people take these words too
literally and they're like confident
cool and they walk up to a girl truck
tonight take everything into
consideration read the [ __ ] room know
if she's into you you can't just take
these things just word for word even
with a lot of [ __ ] guys [ __ ] fail
like cuz I know because my fan base like
I even gotten some messages like yeah
I've tried oz like well how did you do
it and they did that thing where they
they took one part of the advice and
they didn't listen to everything else
yeah so they're like I have to be
confident so I'm just gonna start
approaching women and just go crazy I've
got to be confident I'm gonna start
approaching women it didn't work [ __ ]
women people are born yeah yeah yeah
it's it's real rough but I feel like we
covered some and then physically
seriously like David said you could do
this right now
haircut go get a good haircut get a nice
put a nice white t-shirt on some nice
shirt some nice shoes Bernie or put a
little put a little Cologne on okay wait
is this wack four guys four girls it's
so fun to go to like a perfume store or
a cent store and like to smell different
things and find what feels like you yeah
I feel like that's not that hard for
dudes like how I feel like that's kind
of fun like you won't smell like leather
a little bit of wood a little bit of
butter I don't know what you're like
when you go on a date and you hug the
guy and the Cologne lingers on you all
right oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
simple tips to that just guys don't
really think about right it's very very
[ __ ] simple you it's like almost
giving them something to remember you by
and scent is very strong oh I remember
this scent it was that one dude that I
used to date back in the he used to wear
this cologne yeah or or you know what
subconsciously you're telling a woman I
care about myself right and it's just
your physical thing but we love a man
that cares about himself because when
you're thirsty and you give it all the
way for me I don't want that I want you
to love yourself and care about yourself
and take care of yourself so I think
we're gonna end here and like you know
we always you know we'd be out here we'd
be given that hot advice make sure you
subscribe check out the episodes every
Tuesday you miss a Tuesday backtrack you
clean and put this [ __ ] on the TV hang
out with us we'll give you all the
straight facts and ladies I feel like
most of you guys might agree with what
we said cuz this is just like it's just
more stuff more guys we wish they did
right and don't forget to check out
David and genius brain yeah that's all
of his stuff you have a show coming up
right do what I don't know I guess it's
either no well I don't think those
things are open though but I'm gonna be
in New York and Jersey for a couple
established Boise Joisey you guys will
see me pop up on a Netflix show this
this summer around there no you guys
take care of me I try to do [ __ ] do it I
said this before I'm like I'm riding
David's coattails to the top yeah
alright we love y'all take care of
yourself let me know if you want me back
all of you
yeah we'll see you baby